[Music]
Tom I'm standing outside where a
vigilante has declared war on crime in
South Park security camera footage
showed a young person 40 people spaces
on their balls it was just terrifying
you ain't never heard a fart like this
man the kick just started farting on
people it was out of nowhere now how
long before he or she kills an innocent
person
how long before daredevil becomes the
Punisher huh 3 season 3 season climate
out of control in our town [ __ ] and
friends are this city's only hope
all right you need to go out into the
count and do superhero stuff you know
help people and fight crime and dump
[ __ ] like that
how's the character she heading
that you do it back there's nothing
that's clock back
do not give me those sad puppy eyes you
are not going to have three classes
I've been given $20,000 to take care of
you but but I only need a few hungry for
that so you know what I'm gonna do with
all the rest go to Paris again a P
toilet has been in [ __ ] French chicks
super Craig don't forget to bring the
tile
you